so if you're a sub you can
make your name purple like these people
i've never played never never played
fussro da
i like the name ends with da okay let's
play
and good luck oh why is my profile
picture like that
uh someone in the youtube comments told
me to
change my my profile picture to the
pumpkin image
so i listened so let's play um this is
an albin
counter gambit
this is what borgov played against beth
harmon
i think in one of the games
surprise opening i hope that doesn't
give away any spoilers
whoa it's emblem emblem gifting five
subs
thanks so much gifting to
oh that's a difficult name per
project bridge devlin
queenie though slums on fire secret
crocodile
and ambotes really appreciate that
okay so we have some actually some
normal structure
yeah the benefit here for black is that
i'm castled
and i can start pressuring the e-file
before white has a chance to castle
and here i think i just take the pawn
and then try and defend the pawn so
white wants to take i realize you were
oh oh maybe i confused some people
i'll i'll change my photo picture my
profile picture
back uh probably after the stream
once halloween passes
but thanks for subbing and thanks for
joining
even though you didn't recognize it at
first
m soul 90.
um so i was attacking two things this
defends
both things
i think i'll continue to apply pressure
the knight's still pinned now i have
three attackers against e3 there's only
two defenders
so the bishop should probably move
ah i was hoping the bishop would move is
in the remaining ideas but
okay let's take a thing
but which thing
i'm realizing if takes takes
takes takes takes there's takes
and then takes takes takes
uh i'm attacking this but f7 is kind of
[Music]
vulnerable i mean takes takes knight
check should be okay for me
up two pawns in that line
yeah that's a lot of
there's gonna be a lot of captures in a
row coming up
it's risky because like f7 is vulnerable
and i'm really not developed on the
queen side
but i'm winning pawns so
i hope that counts for something
okay so we just captured wow how many
captures one two
three four five six seven eight nine
nine opponent wants to meet me
let's not get mated oh
i might be in trouble
that was a good move white's pieces are
like about to pounce
hmm i could make looft
but okay rookie is threatening to win
the bishop too i want to play this move
maybe it's playable
i'll just have to pray for the best
this is actually really risky for me
i'm not sure if white has anything
but i guess this is what i get for
being so ambitious in the opening
that's a good move because it defends
and now there's
there's three attackers against my pawn
only one defender
so i'm gonna have to do this not what i
want to do
but what else
the good thing is that it's kind of
close to equal material
because white white's going to be up the
exchange but i'll have two pawns for it
and then hopefully i can complete
development
peacefully this move but then d5
maybe this move
i think this is okay
okay so i'm making luft i'm also
preventing knight e5 whoa
it's nz chess player thanks for reading
nz probably stands for new zealand
thanks so much welcome
uh if you're just joining i'm kind of in
trouble
okay let's play this move no loses a
pawn
actually it's tricky
yeah someone gave a shout out to nz
chess player i gotta focus
uh this my opening play backfired
i'm down to exchange
i'm not getting mated immediately
but the rook is so active okay the
knight's pinned
so there's some tricks here
uh the most logical move is rook takes
c7
which i'm not actually sure if it's good
white doesn't go for it yeah rook c7 i
had knight a6
probably gonna have to play knight a6
just to defend and get my rook into the
game
it's a sad place for the knights
but ok i'm controlling controlling the
key squares
there's increment so my time isn't too
well that was a good move play this move
time shouldn't be too worrisome
uh-oh
what's going on here
yeah very tricky position
opponent's getting low on time too
okay so rook takes b7 i think would have
led to a good position for white
but now i think i can breathe
comfortably
except ooh rookie 7 is still coming
that's not what i wanted oh it's this is
still a fight
uh i have to move the knight no let's
defend the pawn first
knights defended
so i am technically up material
but it's tricky because white has a an
outside passer
okay now at least my king can come into
play into play
king d7
i might end up losing one of these pawns
but then the rook will be out of play
hopefully
this move
oh i'm actually winning the pawn knight
c4 coming
okay this should be winning for me
but it still takes a lot of work
oh there's a cool mating idea king f4
i'll bring my knight to f1
oh it might happen too
it might not happen though
i might win on time do it do it do it do
it do it
ah i want a g5 mate
uh okay
we'll dance around for a little bit
okay now this pawn is weak
okay
increments nice and play a lot of quick
moves gain time
what are the odds white gets forked
a very hard fought game though
now i still want to go for this mating
idea
uh let's play this move
just do this
uh okay i should probably advance upon
soon
i'm playing like very uh low-risk chess
everything's covered
okay there's the fork
took some effort there okay
yeah that would have been tragic if i
accidentally like repeated the position
good game though opponent's uh opponent
weathered the storm from the opening
and then i think i was
yeah it was probably worse around here
and then this was this was a very
critical moment
because it looks like i'm delivering the
tactic
um it's trying to remove the knight from
defending the rook
and then i won the knight but white
could have
uh taken the pawn
going up a pawn and then if i take the
knight i lose the bishop
so this would have been yeah this would
have been
really difficult to come back from